the soup is dead
buried I guess Henry Cavill bleeds
should we make fun of him he's made a
lot of money we can make it fun I'm a
little bit that mustache though right
Greg jonald ha we are going to talk
about some news that's kind of bumming
me out a little bit actually something
that wasn't and think would bum me out
I'm pretty bummed but before we go into
that let me say thank you to everyone
who's been joining our patreon page
people we got weekly Q&A is where we
take a question from a patron and then
we do a full video response to it
exclusively on patreon and we also do TV
show reactions that we post pretty much
six days a week I would love it if you
guys could go check out our patron
anyway
smooth transition the first thing I
literally first thing I saw an hour and
a half ago when I woke up was Henry
Cavill is not Superman anymore
everyone's talking about a man
everyone's talking about it this comes
from The Hollywood Reporter we're gonna
read through this article I wanted to
say man I just Henry calles got some
weirdest career luck I've ever seen man
babies start to make you wonder if that
Superman curse might be real because
it's been almost nothing but a mess yeah
the beginning I mean like Man of Steel's
about the quietest moment the DC EU as a
whole is had Man of Steel was I was a
good film we've talked about Henry
Cavill quite a bit from going on other
channels and talking here I said it
before that it's not that I don't think
the guy's a good actor he I just haven't
seen him in anything I'm gonna preface
this with I haven't seen the Man From
UNCLE which is the the role everyone
goes to for like you should have seen
the man from you know from like the
other big works I've seen him in the
including fallout I haven't seen him in
something where I'm like wow he really
really stole the show for me he really
stands out a lot he's a powerful
performer he's usually just kind of
stiff he looks the part but I like him
yes you see what I have with Emily I
like him I've been waiting this Eamon
something that really gives him a whole
lot to work with because I don't doubt
that he could nail yeah you know and
it's kind of weird how he has the
Justice League to boggle
and that movie kind of flops fallout
comes out which is I think the most
financially successful movie in the
franchise now which is good for him and
everyone's like the most of us was worth
it and this happens and I'm like dang
man everyone's been trying to get a Man
of Steel to with this get wanting that
for a long time and now it looks like
we're just not getting it alright let's
go through this let's stir from pot
reporter reports here talks broke down
for a cameo in Shazam
due to scheduling conflicts and the door
is now closing on the other potential
appearances for the actor Henry Cavill
who's played Superman three phones as
parting ways with Warner Brothers
Warner's has been trying to enlist cavil
most recent co-starred in Mission
Impossible fall out for Superman cameo
in Shazam the contract talks between
cavils WME rep and Warner Bros broke
down the doors not closing other
potential Superman appearances his
studio has shifted its focus to a
Supergirl movie which would be an origin
story featuring a teen super heroine as
effective it removes an actor cabals age
from the storylines equation giving that
Superman aka call will be an infant
according to DC lore the idea of him
doing a cameo in Shazam is something
that I'm not opposed against actually I
don't think it would steal the show
actually watch the DC animated film that
was like only a half hour long or
something versus an versus black atom
and seen a lot of that lineage is linked
with Superman in that specific animated
films the idea of Superman being a
bitter sends like a cool prospect yeah
but I can you know live or die without
him this part of the storyline though
and it's not like movie franchises take
the comic-book lore like yeah hundred
percent we have to stick to that like
they change things all the time and I
don't see why they couldn't change
something like that or at least adjusted
furthermore Warner's isn't likely to
make a solo Superman film for at least
several years according to another
source Superman is like James Bond and
after a certain run you have to look at
new actors as a studio source as such
cavil will join Ben Affleck and I've
been seeing reports coming out this
morning - who isn't expected to reprise
his role for director Matt Reeves
forthcoming Batman standalone film as a
hero on the way out guys like Ben
Affleck alright I think it's becoming
too much of a
at this point you know like especially
with the fact that he just went back
into rehab he keeps checking in and out
of rehab he's traveling right yes it
seems like a Warner source says this
Shazam deal fell apart because of
scheduling conflicts and I was backed up
by the fact that cavil recently signed
on mr. on that Netflix series The
Witcher I mean that's cool maybe he was
part of the tutors oh that is holy all
things worthy and good to you I think
that's when people really started to
actually notice him Jesus got so and
doing The Witcher video game series you
know and he's already part of the victim
world in a lot of ways yeah pretty cool
idea and I mean with the enthusiasm
that's surrounded at least The Witcher 3
I got to imagine that that's probably a
step up from yeah there's a recognition
that some parts of the previous movies
didn't works as a studio insider another
source says Warner's is trying to hit a
reset button with the DC Universe
steering and ships slowly in another
direction obviously well Affleck and
cavil are segwaying out others who were
seen together on screen and Jessica are
carrying forward yes yes I'm aware of
all that stuff yeah the flash movie will
never get made I don't care what
everyone says the one just a couple days
ago they were talking about whether or
not this cyborg movie would get dumped
and I feel like that of all time
probably has the worst chances because
they've struggled this much with flash
and that's a character people know
really well here's what's weird is in
general not in love with the Superman
character and I got the shirt general my
lover the Superman character take that
and I'm not in love with what Henry
Cavill is didn't give an opportunity to
do with Man of Steel I liked the trend
that some people thought it was weird
and Justice League but I actually really
liked when he was really charming
Superman in Justice League there are two
weeks well
I believe in truth but I'm also a big
fan of justice so I was looking forward
to more to that I was looking forward
and I was like man if we get that Man of
Steel to with more Superman energy and
he's got that Superman charm that he was
showing off and Justice League I'm
pretty excited for that Henry Cavill is
constantly teetering on the line of he's
about to blow me away he hasn't quite
done something that really hit the mark
for me in that department I'm weirdly
bummed about this yeah like comfort for
him might cuz yeah as I don't think he
wanted to really land here if that makes
I feel like the DCU for a lot of people
has been like a sort of weird nightmare
that was supposed to be a wonderful
dream you never gotta except for gal
gadot yeah for everybody else it seems
to be one of those things where you're
sold a dream and you get this sort of
disappointing yeah it's mostly I'm
bummed because I thought that I could
just saw always see the potential for
him to be a great Superman and I don't
think they ever gave him material that
approached that potential and so yeah
it's a bummer that this whole DC you
seems to be kind of going that way with
a couple exceptions but at the same time
I'm like I don't know how much better
this is gonna get granted they're gonna
change stuff like if they kept the
course the same I don't know how much
better it would get and I don't know how
much better it's gonna get up to change
stuff but at this point I think they
need changes well it sounds like what
they're doing is they're focusing on
more female led superhero films they got
the Wonder Woman 1984 coming out you got
Aquaman who looks like a woman in some
angles yeah no you got one room in 1984
you got you know 14 Harley Quinn movies
and development yeah sources are correct
and they're shifting focus towards a
Supergirl movie my issue with all of
this is it seems like a lot of these
projects are going for without having a
clear-cut idea who's gonna be your
Superman who's gonna be your Batman and
a DC Universe without Superman and
Batman seems kind of strange it's like I
feel like they'll exist in some way and
I know Matt Reeves is working on it
that's another project Rome like is this
really the other
line up in development held to kind of
like doing you know venom movie that's
my all these weird decisions and it
seems like nobody can just get their
[ __ ] together I'm a little bit bummed
I've heard of stories turning around it
sounds like there's some probably you
know they're saying scheduling conflicts
is probably some contract negotiation
probably yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah some
of the articles I read hinted toward the
idea that communicate like negotiations
turnaround sometimes you hear with that
one way and then they come back a few
months later like oh we figured it out
because this is the big talk and we kind
of live in this movie news internet
world where the second something is
rumored or or being talked about it
becomes a headlines like I somebody even
yeah he might be leaving everyone's
auntie ia baby I was a headline just
even a 1% chance and worried that Warner
Brothers hasn't spoken on it themselves
or Henry Cavill hasn't come out about it
themselves it's not entirely official
yet
what's gonna happen is he's gonna come
out and say no I'm gonna be Superman for
a very long time and then a month later
they're gonna be like it's official he's
out yeah
all right guys well how you feel about
this news do you think we should get a
new Superman Tom Hardy no Eaters Elba
mark my words movie fights tomorrow who
should be the new Superman I was caged
it's time this cage man gets your second
shot man let's do this well thanks for
watching what do you guys think of this
news are you bummed you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and hey check us out
on patreon got TV show reactions q a's
bunch of goodies love to have you become
tragic today